[Music]
singer/songwriter Steve malcolmus has
been described as a patron saint of
indie rock the frontman for the 90s
group pavement he just released a
seventh album with his current band the
chicks will hear selections in just a
moment first Anthony Mason sat down with
malcolmus to talk about his ongoing
influence on the indie scene most beat
makers don't do it this way but
did it Stephen Malkmus has a peculiar
place in the music pantheon and he knows
it
where do you see yourself in all those
I'm on the outside looking in always you
know like that behind that glass
knocking
GQ magazine recently called the 52 year
old frontman of Stephen Malkmus and the
jix the dad of indie rock
let me feel about that title I'd rather
be the dad than the granddad or the
great granddad
[Music]
he's best known for his work with the
band pavement whose debut record slanted
and enchanted is considered one of the
most influential albums of the 90s a lot
of nineties bands have kind of been
making comebacks and recently when you
see an era that you kind of arrived in
suddenly making a comeback how do you
perceive that you think the nineties is
having at the moment now you're saying
yeah um well I think that's a good thing
because that benefits me I hope that
goes on forever
[Music]
but his new record with the chicks
Sparkle hard is his 7th with the band is
it something you just have to do at this
point or is it something you have to
make yourself to to me I think of the
future writing Tunes you know like
something Goods gonna happen I'm gonna
make something special it's gonna have
magical fairy dust on it and it will
join into the pantheon of other great
magical fairy dust songs that I like
it's not always magical as we talked
malcolmus was still recovering from an
illness he picked up on tour and I don't
know somehow I caught a bug in Toronto
and I lost my voice for two days and I'm
always amazed musicians went there when
they were struggling with their voice
and I have to be humiliating to people
know that I'm not the best singer anyway
and they like me and they know the songs
but still when you don't have a voice
you're put in a point of a most
emotional vulnerability where you you
kind of it's tiring you know emotionally
weary to be there and have people
worrying about you and then you feel a
little like you have to give even more
when you just like to play your songs
have them sound great say a couple witty
words and be on your way
[Laughter]